Hemoglobin molecules normally stick together and interact with each
other and they're packed into a very small space
to carry lots of oxygen, like you see on
the left. We call this normal hemoglobin data, we
call it the HbA allele. But the glutamate to
valine mutation which we refer to as the HBS
allele, causes the overall hemoglobin molecule to stick together
more than it normally does. And this abnormal interaction
of sticking together more than it normally does,
leads to these elongated stretches of hemoglobin molecules.
This has the effect of altering the shape
of the red blood cell from this sort of
more oval rounded shape. To this elongated sickle
shape here. So in this scenario do you think
that the HbS allele, the mutant allele is
an example of a loss of function, a gain
of function, or a no change in function allele?